cours de sciences sociales collège
visitation la berrière la critique des
sources par sylvain drame et vous vous
promenez en ville soudain vous tombez
sur un morceau de pizza
vous avez très fin mais vous n'allez pas
manger ce morceau de pizza parce que
vous ne mangez pas les morceaux de pizza
inconnu vous allez vous poser de
nombreuses questions sur ce morceau de
pizza comme qui a déposé ce morceau de
pizza s'étendre pourquoi cette pizza et
elle était déposée à cet endroit qu'il a
fait cette pizza quand cette pizza at
elle été préparée et quels sont ces
ingrédients et même si vous répondez à
toutes ces questions
il est très peu probable que vous mangez
cette pizza parce que vous allez
continuer à vous en méfiez vous devez
avoir exactement le même type de
raisonnement pour une information quelle
qu'elle soit vous allez vous poser une
question d'où elle vient comment elle a
été faite avoue partir de quoi at elle
été faite
c'est ce qu'on appelle la critique des
sources la source d'une information
correspond à l'origine de cette
information critique à une source c'est
donc se poser des questions sur
l'origine d'une information et se méfier
mélodiquement de toute information
comment pratiquer la critique des
sources
vous allez distinguer une critique
externe qui va s'occuper des extérieurs
du document plutôt de la forme du
document est une critique interne qui va
plutôt s'intéresser au fond du dos comme
o2 du document à son contenu
en ce qui concerne la critique interne
vous avez essentiellement vous
intéresser à l'auteur qui est son auteur
pour ce faire vous allez reprendre le
nom de l'auteur et maintenant avec les
nouvelles technologies c'est assez
facile vous allez taper son nom dans
google et vous allez directement voir
quel est son profil vous allez aussi
vous posez la question de l'origine du
document plus généralement l'auteur a
été publiée dans quelle revue est-ce que
c'est simplement un blog ou est ce que
c'est le site d'un journal plus
officielle
quel est le statut à la foi de l'auteur
et du lieu où l'article ou le document
est publié
le lieu de publication est aussi
important évidemment
est ce qu'on est vraiment face à une
maison d'édition qui a vérifié les
informations qui a porté une critique à
ces informations ou est-ce qu'il s'agit
vraiment comme on le dit souvent
maintenant un pure player c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui publie directement les
informations sur internet
enfin la date est aussi important est
évidemment car s'il s'agit d'un élément
d'actualité qui date de 2012 c'est que
vous êtes en 2017 cet article n'est plus
très pertinents enfin une série d'autres
éléments sont aussi remarqué comme le
nombre de pages les références
bibliographiques qui doivent être bien
mentionné et la mise en page qui peut
aussi donner des indices sur le sérieux
de la publication en ce qui concerne la
critique est interne on va
essentiellement s'intéresser au contenu
même du document on rentre donc dans le
document on va regarder sa structure est
ce que le propos est cohérent est ce
qu'il est bien organisé en paragraphes
est-ce que les éléments sont pertinents
est-ce que ça a du sens l'orthographe
est il correct alors c'est important
puisque l'orthographe correcte voudrait
dire que le document a été relu a été
préparé a été retravaillée est ce que le
vocabulaire employé est bien celui qui
doit être employée si vous avez des gros
mots dans un document si vous avez des
insultes dans document on peut douter de
la pertinence et la fiabilité de celui
ci est ce qu'ils on est en face d'un
jugement de réalité est-ce qu'on est en
face de faits qui peuvent être vérifiés
via d'autres sources ou est ce que c'est
vraiment un ressenti un jugement de
valeur que l'auteur porte sur des
éléments petit exercice pratique pour
appliquer cette critique des sources sur
un cas concret amiens pour ne pas
déplaire à la communauté musulmane le
marché de noël va changer de nom il
s'appellera désormais marché d'hiver
français qu'attendez vous bougez vous il
s'agit d'un message qui a été partagé de
nombreuses fois en en fin 2014 sur le
réseau social facebook c'est d'ailleurs
là que
je les ai retirées à ce moment là on va
se poser les questions tout d'abord sur
pour faire la critique externe est tout
d'abord qui a publié ce message c'est un
certain groupe peuple de france réveille
toi france est d'abord un groupe public
on voit qu'il s'agit déjà quelque chose
qui est très proche de l'extrême droite
ou réveille toi le réveille toi montre
qu'on veut amener les gens à faire
quelque chose qu'il ne s'agit pas
simplement de dénoncer des faits ici on
veut vraiment amener les gens à faire
quelque chose donc c'est déjà un indice
pour nous dire que cet article et quand
même légèrement peu fiables l'auteur de
ce post est un certain jean bastide vous
voyez sur sa photo la mémoire des ovnis
donc en plus de faire de la politique et
de vouloir réveiller les consciences il
veut il s'intéresse aux ovnis donc on a
là un mélange qui s'accommodent mal
finalement d'une rigueur intellectuelle
puisque si vous êtes spécialiste des
ovnis vous n'êtes pas spécialiste
politique pour autant et inversement
on voit d'ailleurs dans son profil qu'il
est très peu suivie mais ça ce n'est pas
forcément un indice surtout voyez des ga
ce1 à c'est en allant plus loin on voit
qu'il s'agit en fait de secteurs plutôt
lié à l'aéronautique et à l'aérospatiale
donc qui n'a rien à voir finalement avec
les questions de migration ou de
culturalisme ou de religion donc on a
quelqu'un là qui parle en son nom propre
mais finalement qui n'est pas plus
crédible que vous et moi sur la question
quand on cherche sur son profil on voit
qu'ils partagent certains messages
notamment de gilbert collard qui est un
député front national à l'assemblée
nationale et qui est un peu raciste
c'est pas beaucoup
en même temps on voit que marine
présidente s'inscrit sur son profil
donc il est clairement d'obédience fn un
don qu'il soutient le front national est
d'ailleurs vous voyez ici qu'ils
partagent un message avec contactez-nous
soit par mail fn 46 arba seront
national.com
donc c'est quelqu'un a clairement qui
fait de la politique
qui tourne pour le fn mais finalement
qui disséminent qui diffusent des
messages comme cela mais pas pour la
vérité mais plutôt pour convaincre de la
pertinence du message front national
donc ici déjà cet article ou en tout cas
cette publication d'un point de vue de
la critique externe ça ne passe pas
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas fiable
alors c'est voilà monsieur jean bastide
fait ce qu'il veut mais là ils énoncent
des choses qui ne sont pas fiables
maintenant on va passer à la critique
interne et on va les voir à l'intérieur
documents et on constate en fait qu' il
ne s'agit pas de renommer le marché de
noël
d'ailleurs le mot qui l'utilisent n'est
pas correct puisque le véritable titre
du marché de noël d'amiens c'est parfums
divers
et puis qu'on s'intéresse un peu à la
mairie à pourquoi est-ce qu'elle a pris
le nom de parfums divers c'est parce que
marché de noël ne marchait plus il le
marché de noël ne connaissait plus un
certain succès donc ils ont refait si
vous voulez une opération marketing
parfums divers mais qu'un nul n'est ni
lié au fait de vouloir faire plaisir à
qui que ce soit c'est juste du marketing
finalement si vous voulez et d'ailleurs
on voit bien en dessous marché de noël
en dessous qui est remis donc la
publication facebook de monsieur jean
bastide est fausse
en plus de ne pas être crédible est
totalement fausse et si je m'étais
attaché évidemment à la forme de son
petit message
on pourrait tout de suite voir qu'il
s'agissait d' un ignoble montage avec
des caractères vraiment me plic ploc que
vous et moi nous aurions pu faire voyez
ici la pertinence d'une critique des
sources 1 et la première chose à faire
en tant que citoyens responsables
c'est que quand vous voyez une
information comme ça sur facebook
posez-vous ces questions avant de
partager benoîtement
merci de votre attention et à très
bientôt